here in the valley of pinning ceremony
was held for veterans at cactus valley
retirement resort jeremy j ford was
there as local heroes were honored i
guess it's a recognition
of
the service that i put in u.s air force
veteran bob stein is one of many being
recognized at the procare hospice
ceremony there was a long time when
veterans weren't
[Music]
talking
and now they're being recognized i think
it
[Music]
it's also time for us to hold a place
to recognize those men and women who
have been willing to put their lives on
the line so we can enjoy the freedoms
that we have each veteran honored
received a congressional certificate
during the ceremony as we live in a
country especially one today that has
been so divided it is important that we
remember our commitment to upholding our
democracy and to take time to properly
thank those who gave their service and
for some their lives for all americans
the sacrifices haven't always been
acknowledged a lot of the vets coming
off the airplanes were being sped upon
i'm not sure where the change came from
but i'm uh
jeremy j ford live local now